let's get into audience questions for
the week the first one is from Ken Ken
wants to know hey David are race-based
dating preferences and sexual
preferences a form of racism so I'm
going to answer this as asked because
there is you know sort of the most
narrow answer to a question like this
but it's important to understand that I
mentioned this before very often these
types of questions are not asked in good
faith and I'm not saying ken is not
asking the question in good faith it's
just important to understand how very
often there are people who ask these
questions in order to elicit a
particular answer which then is used to
justify some further bad argument or bad
take and I don't want to be doing that
so I'll sort of get to that in a little
bit so in the most technical sense is
something like I'm a white male I am not
attracted to Asian women or black women
is that racism if you want to play the
linguistic game strictly speaking that
is something called sexual racism
now don't be triggered by the word okay
we're trying to have adult conversation
conversations here we're trying to have
conversations that have context so don't
just go crazy because I'm calling
something racism this is actually a deep
topic with a lot of nuance behind it and
there's really a lot of sociology and a
lot of things behind this on the one
hand people are attracted to certain
other people oftentimes for reasons that
are not particularly discernible
sometimes people have a preference for
thinner or heavier of others sometimes
for certain hair colors sometimes
complexions certain personalities assert
certain hobbies or religion or skin
color right race is a completely
reasonable basis where one might have a
sort of base level predisposition in
favor of or against when it comes to
physical attraction and in principle
this is no big deal
this
not evidence of systemic cultural racism
this it's none of those things
okay now let's go beyond that there is
also a reality that sometimes those
preferences can be culturally ingrained
through discriminatory or racist
messages that are sometimes reinforced
by society and culture so for example
some countries have caste systems and
those caste systems can pervade so
strongly that people believe that
something is merely a casual preference
about physical appearance for example
but it's actually ingrained
multi-generationally by teaching that
people of a certain caste are dirty or
toxic or to be avoided or whatever and
it's important to understand that you
might think I just happen not to be
attracted to X and X could be a racial
characteristic or it could be a physical
characteristic of some other kind or
whatever the case may be and you may not
even have an awareness that it is
something cultural that has been
ingrained that is actually responsible
for that does that mean that it should
be enforced that even if you don't find
certain races attractive you should have
to date them of course not
of course not we're not talking about
that we're just trying to have a more
nuanced than deep understanding of where
some of these preferences can come from
in the United States - you know the
caste example is not super relevant in
the u.s. in the u.s. attitudes towards
interracial relationships do affect
attitudes about other races sexually
which can translate to someone thinking
I just happen not to be attracted to
someone from a certain race but it could
be connected to historical
discrimination and taboos about
interracial marriage which fortunately
are less prevalent in 2019
than they were 50 years ago but still to
some degree exist
I know people who tend to date only
outside their race I know both men and
women that are heterosexual and I know
gay men all of whom have dating
preferences that are for those who
are not part of their racial group it
could be by chance it could be connected
to something in their upbringing who
knows so that's the analysis in a
literal sense sexual racism is a thing
and I apologize for hitting my
microphone there is this the type of
systemic racism that is endemic of is is
a prototypical of the problems in
society no it's not and I'm not saying
that and that's where I think the
broader analysis comes in the reality is
that making questions of racism about
something like sexual preferences is
very often a distraction sometimes used
in bad faith by people who either want
to create fake drama around dating
preferences or to use acceptance for
dating preferences on the basis of race
to justify further segregation there is
a case that some on the internet like to
make that listen if it's okay
to only want to date people of certain
races then what's the big deal with more
segregation like why don't we live
around people of our own race and the
next thing you know you're talking about
something like what Richard Spencer has
proposed a peaceful segregation on the
races of base so it's important I'm glad
to address these questions as if they
are good faith questions and I believe
with peace and love that Ken was asking
it in good faith but I would be doing
you a disservice if I didn't tell you
that these types of questions are often
used by bad faith actors to either trick
or induce fruitless or false debates
that are really a distraction from the
issues that as a society we're trying to
solve if you disagree with me let me
know I can't wait to hear from you